new court documents reveals more about
Epstein's relationship with JPMorgan
Chase
reveal a deeper relationship between
Jeffrey Epson and JP Morgan Chase with
prosecutors filing exhibits containing
hundreds of new emails the bank accused
of facilitating Epstein's child sex
trafficking operation and has been
criticized for slow document uh
production the involvement of JPMorgan
CEO Jamie Diamond ramiza Central remains
a central question while an email
implicates him in approving a 120
million dollar transfer the bank claims
Diamond was unaware of Epstein as a
client Epstein has direct contact with
multiple Bank employees including Jess
Staley the head of the wealth and later
Investment Banking divisions who
received business advice and connections
Staley allegedly supplied Epstein with
confidential information and favors in
exchange for Bank turning a blind eye to
his sex trafficking convictions dailies
association with Epson led to his
resignation as Barclay CEO Vinnie what
do we know it's like right just when you
think that I've seen stuff is like dying
out or something's like gonna stop it's
like it it keeps coming it's like a it's
the Epstein Saga anything that has to do
with covering up this pedophilia ring it
it's happening like like when he when he
got suicided in jail it's like a bad uh
murder mystery the cameras were off
people weren't looking the driver did
this by the way JP Morgan and Jeffrey
nepstein emails were released and now
Pat this was a couple days ago they
mistakenly JP Morgan mistakenly deleted
47 emails the security Exchange
Commission find Chase only four million
dollars how convenient all the business
records which are supposed to hold for
three years under the SEC rules were
deleted data from January 1st to April
23 2018 they were deleted in June 2019
from uh 8 700 mailboxes uh including
those belonging to as many 7 500
employees and it's like Pat and then a
random I swear to you I was telling Rob
this I was waiting for somebody to
either accidentally pass away or
something like that Jim Crown who's a
board member of JP Morgan Chase died on
Sunday in a random plane crash and let's
not forget Pat they just paid Chase
290 million dollars for all these other
situations with everything with the uh
where was it Rob where the island and
all that situation let's it's it's hush
money they were hoping that that money
would have everybody shut up but it's
and again going back to the the they're
in on it Chase bank is in on all this
[__] with Epstein and now what they just
they're being accused they're being
accused of a pat they're paying these
little FL 200 million dollars is nothing
to Chase bank and then again we're
accidentally you miss as well this was
290 million dollars alleging it
knowingly uh benefited from direct line
Jeffrey up to six trafficking according
to a court filing Tuesday lawyers of
Epstein's victims filed a notice of
settlement in Manhattan saying the deal
has approved the deal and so on the
tournament will go to a class of women
who claim to have been victims of
Epstein as much as 30 set aside for
their lawyers according to the filings
to a 70 went to the women yeah wow and
again this is hush money Vinnie let me
type I don't know man I don't know if
people think that banks are willing to
turn a blind eye to this type of stuff
and and throw their morals out the
window for money okay I don't know if
banks these days are willing to put
profits ahead of people I don't know if
banks are willing to do that there's
been no indications that Banks like this
like Deutsche Bank or Wells Fargo yeah
or any of these banks are willing to
basically throw all their moral
convictions out the window for a blank
check yeah Vinnie I'm not sure
am I right I don't think that these
Banks would ever ever do something
unscrupulous like I always had the big
short now we have the big screws
the movie's coming yeah it's just and
again we talked about this for how many
weeks about accountability they're not
going to do 290 million is nothing this
whole situation with kids and I'm going
back to that the war the the war of good
and evil evil is just it's just kicking
out
follow the money brother okay there's
got to do some money laundering and
washing it around and if some of the
Epstein people are willing to basically
whitewash 300 million dollars whatever
the number is they'll be a bank willing
to do that I guarantee you that well I'm
I'm with Chase and I'm going to be
leaving Chase very shortly no I think we
should also see here what was it 40
million dollars was the supplemental
fine for the no four four million for
for deleting 47 million emails
mistakenly somebody said whoops you know
how that works it goes like this you're
my attorney yeah hey Vinnie yep if um
this is kind of weird so if these if
these emails get out what's the penalty
well they already they already did 290
million dollars could be another couple
hundred million dollars yeah but what's
up what's a fine from this FEC for
basically four million ish not not too
crazy why okay well let's just uh okay
we'll just add that to the cost of the
suit and uh let's uh let's do what we
gotta do okay so just pull the trigger
happens every day and whether and by the
way it's sad but this is part of the
corruption and the two levels of justice
that we have in this country you know
the wealthy are able to make these
decisions hide behind it stall the suit
all these things like this and evidence
is you know uh withheld destroyed and
things like this
um sorry to be a downer but let's just
talk about what the reality is and to
your point that you made very loud and
sarcastically you're absolutely right
they're like
you know what kind of business are you
in well I do this and this and I do this
and this anybody knows the story of
Pablo Escobar they know there was two
Regional Miami Banks and basically the
Central Bank of Panama that were turning
a blind eye to Pablo Escobar because
they had massive deposits that the bank
took in Miami massive deposits and then
they they were loaning those out as home
loans and car loans and had a very fine
little business because you need what
assets to make loans so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]